for Turkey's president wretched type
Berta one is giving a media conference
at the moment let's listen in sincere in
sincerest feelings my dear friend
Azerbaijan presidents of the lef in my
invitation between 14th of October and
15th of October we are going to visit
Azerbaijan and we're going to depart to
Bucky to join the summit with our
representatives and a large delegation
is going to be after arriving baku first
of all i'm going to meet my brother i
know that we are going to business conse
in baku we're going to meet businessman
living outside turkey turkey conse
seventh summit is important historically
first of all the summit is relationship
importance relationships between
Azerbaijan Kurdistan Azerbaijan
especially related to the not Iran
treaty and this is going siding with the
10th anniversary of the treaty but q
summit will also initiate we're going to
join an opening or in Europe as well and
this will also add strength to our
operation to our cooperation kissed and
Founder especially North Sultana is our
base
[Music]
with this he will be awarded during the
summit experience of oxic oh and we're
going to take benefit of his experiences
hi Felicia Turkish world and the
cooperation will strengthen each day and
this is something to be proud of for us
all the members of the states who will
join the summit we will have bilateral
meetings and hopefully we will have
opportunity to talk about our future
relationships I would like to give also
information about our peace ring
operation to the state leaders to all
the Turkish conse members and as we're
going to have opportunity to strengthen
our relationship with this summit please
from CNN türk Turkish there is
reportedly news about Syrian army is
making deal with YPG how is this going
to affect the operation difference of
course there is a lot of gossip okay but
especially through an ambassadors and in
addition to that at the moment in kobani
with Russia's positive approach it looks
like we're not going to have any
difficulty about mem Beach at the moment
we decided we are going to act on it as
you know with United States about
mintage
discussion with America about marriage
we were saying that in 90 days terror
organizations we're going to exit from a
[ __ ] but this didn't happen so when we
empty members we are not going to enter
moon which we are the real owners of
that area our Arabic brothers are going
to go into that area in Wimbush and our
approach to this is that they should
enter there and we are going to make it
secure for them yesterday United States
Defense Secretary said they were talking
about we throwing the American soldiers
I think this is positive approach I
think this is still ongoing and there's
nothing against us at the moment
our soldiers are determined in the Syria
operation and there is a lot of effort
to not to harm any civilians but some of
the foreign media is reporting it in a
different way some there are some masala
and some staged things another foreign
reporter were claiming that they heard
bombing near civilian areas difference I
believe these manipulations how you
evaluate this this is how I evaluated to
fix hundreds more than 600 Marta
shelling to our country but they don't
see this they are blind to this of
course this is not acceptable I'm not
but this is not a first this is always
their tactic
and at the moment this is the same
tactic inside and outside they do the
same tactic but of course the truth to
cover the truth is not possible because
at the moment we have martyrs we have
civilians who died and as a result of
these martyrs shelling we have
casualties we have injured we have
people who are displaced have moved out
our civilians are citizens they can try
to manipulate as much as they like but
our people are seeing the truth and we
are going to express this through
written and and Broadcasting vehicles
Via Media of course they are going to
put their effort they going to do their
tricks but we are going to continue
telling the truth
this is not going to stop us this is not
going to prevent us do you want to
[Music]
related to my friends questions
there are many strong reactions from
countries and there are some
contradictory expressions of statements
some of the countries having
self-criticism what are you going to say
about are you talking about the Arab
League yes Arab League and in West sand
countries there are some there is some
self-criticism maybe they are saying
last week Turkey has got a right to do
this operation what are you doing to say
about this of course these reactions
will change because as you know liars
can't last forever and at the moment
what's happening at the moment they can
see all this I have spoken to shun
Chancellor Marko
yesterday a day before that I spoken to
Lois Johnson in my meeting in in my
conversation with them I realized that
they don't know many important truths
they're not aware and they are under
very strong misinformation campaign I
explained to them if you want to have a
sincere approach here we you are in the
coalition powers we are in the coalition
powers to within the coalition are you
looking for truth here oh of course they
are trying to hide something that we
have what is it we another ally be
careful all these countries are NATO
members the fifth article of NATO we are
under attack from a terror organization
according to the fifth article
who should they be siding with with us
but with a NATO member are you going to
be with your nutr NATO ally or are you
going to be with who are you going to be
with are you going to be with the
terrorists of course they can't answer
this all the things they do what are
they intending what is their reason it's
impossible to understand sometimes one
thing amongst all the NATO members we
aren't the only Muslim countries is it
because of that maybe because it looks
like it's going this way and of course
we know this terrorist groups nature
and of course NATO one of its
responsibilities is fighting against
terror so but it is passive in front of
the fifth articles but of course the
general secretary of NATO stole some
bath of course I met him he met my state
secretary it was a very good meeting
I think his stand is very different but
member country some of the member
countries their standpoint is different
and after talking to them though for
example especially in mr. Boris Johnson
then he said to me how can I help you
now so he came to this point of course
at this point we have to stand up
straight especially now against terror
and terror organizations you know we
have no problem in the region with
Kurdish we are not fighting against its
heard we have a terror organization
against us we you don't have a war with
the terror organization you fight
against them wars are between states we
have to show the sensitivity so
according to this this is how we
continue I another odd and moon bit at
the moment this is continuing in
addition to that United States and with
Russia continuing with our defense
ministry they are continuing in
communication with them and this
progress this process is going to
continue with determination and you are
publishing all the numbers at the moment
we had naturally neutralized 550
terrorists and amongst this 500 500
casualties dead and 24 sir
so with this way we are going to
continue our fight with determination
yes thank you
hopefully our program will continue
today and tomorrow and tomorrow night we
will return hopefully all right that was
turkeys president Irwin speaking ahead
of his trip to the Baku summit in
Azerbaijan speaking about Turkey's
operation in northern Syria he said
their withdrawal of US troops from that
region is a positive development
describing negative media reports of the
operation he said it was manipulation by
the media on criticism of the operation
by both European and Arab leaders he
said that they're not aware of many
important details they are subject to
disinformation we are under attack by a
terrorist organization he said under the
fifth article of NATO's Constitution
NATO members Western European leaders
should be siding with us he said is it
because we are a Muslim country he
characterized turkeys operation in
northern Syria as a fight against a
terror organization it's not a war he
said war wars are between countries
that's bringing out a 0zm co-ceo who's
with us live from Istanbul said what did
you make of that well in President
eridan first seems to seem to target
international public opinion because in
Ankara there is a perception in the
Turkish capital that Turkey is winning
this conflict the battle or the fight
conflict however you name it or
President Erdogan names it on the ground
but on the PR side on about creating a
public opinion which can understand
Turkish narrative they feel like they
are failing that's why since yesterday
president Arden seems to take over the
duty for international communication
about this military operation conducted
in North
he actually admit that there is an
understanding with Russia because he
said Russia is positive about kobani
where the PYD is active and where the US
troops have withdrawn yet last night and
he said that Turkish military and
Turkish government are determined about
their plan for members you remember like
a year ago Turkey and the u.s. agreed on
a plan which which was called manwich
roadmap and according to that plan
within 90 days the US military will
would was supposed to withdraw from
Mitch and then there would be joined
patrols and everything but he said it's
been more than a year but it didn't
happen so this is this is what we are
planning to do and in each chance for
instance Aragon and his his team has
accused the United States for not
sticking with the Moomba truth and
despite a politically and militarily
they had agreed on this branch so he
showed that they are determined yes what
are we what to make of that that
criticism of Chancellor Merkel and
president McCraw he mentioned Boris
Johnson as well he said that under NATO
articles article number five then they
should be siding with us as as a fellow
member a fellow NATO member he said that
those leaders are subject to
disinformation that they they're not in
possession of all the facts they don't
realize what is actually happening on
the ground in northern Syria exactly I
mean last week a NATO secretary-general
mr. Stoltenberg was in Istanbul he made
a private talk with President aired on
he and foreign minister had a bilateral
it at a TED talk and then they had a
presser and in that presence Stoltenberg
obviously confessed that there were
there was the NATO members have
different points of people about the YPG
and PKK so it seems that it seems that
the the member countries haven't agreed
on how to call the PKK or the YPG or
what kind of
threat day they are they think to appear
to be receiving from them and Turkish
Foreign Minister said that Turkey we
know that in your assessment reports
intelligence reports you have assessed
the YPG because of its links with the
PKK as a threat to NATO and its member
countries but because of the pressure of
some countries especially led by the US
you took this out from your report and
we all know about this he said so that's
why they kind of they kind of feel those
countries especially France and Germany
are biased yesterday in his press her
president aired on said that when I'm
talking to Chancellor America I'm asking
her I'm saying that why did why do you
do it target Turkey about this and then
she begins to say nine nine which is
know in German so this is what he's
trying to say and after his talk with a
prime minister Johnson he said that he
came to a point how can we help to
Turkey so there is a kind of
misunderstanding or miscommunication or
interest parties in other countries have
different opinions this is the first
action in Ankara and that's why I read
on targets the leaders by himself in
order to communicate all right so that
many thanks indeed al Jazeera simcha co2
that live in Istanbul